SO NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY OLD
MacDONALD HAD A SONG.
(APPLAUSE)
YOU KNOW, ONE THING YOUTUBE
DID THAT IT DOESN'T GET
ENOUGH CREDIT FOR IS
USHERING IN A GOLDEN AGE OF
SONG PARODIES.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO
STRETCH THE MEANING OF
GOLDEN AGE A LOT.
AND THERE IS AN ODDLY
SPECIFIC SUBCULTURE OF
FARMING SONGS MADE BY THE
RANCH HANDS AND FARM WORKERS
OF THE HEARTLAND.
I WILL SHOW YOU A CLIP OF A
FARMER SONG PARODY.
FOR 250 POINTS I WANT YOU TO
GIVE ME THE ANSWER TO A
FOLLOWUP QUESTION.
FIRST UP, WE HAVE ALL BEEN
WONDERING WHAT DOES THE
FARMER SAY?
♪ WHAT DOES THE FARMER SAY
♪.
>> WORK, WORK, WORK, WORK,
WORK, ♪
♪ WORK, WORK, WORK, WORK
♪.
>> WHAT DOES THE FARMER
SAY ♪
♪ YIP YIP YIP YIP HA
♪ YIP YIP YIP HA
>> OKAY.
NOW I KNOW WE'RE ALL A
LITTLE UPSET RIGHT NOW.
BUT AS THIS GUY'S FARMER BUDDY,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY ABOUT HIS
VIDEO?
>> HARI.
>> MAN, YOU'RE A REAL
STEPHEN SPIELJEW.
>> POINTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> KYLE DUNNIGAN.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE LEARNING.
BURN IT!
>> YUP, POINTS.
MATT BRAUNGER.
>> HEY, MAN, CONGRATS FOR
YOUR 6 MILLION VIEWS. HOPE IT
WAS WORTH DAD LOSING THE FARM
WHILE YOUR SECTION OF THE CROPS
DIED.
IT'S ALL WE [BLEEP] HAD,
CLINT!
>> POINTS.
A LOT OF FAMILY DRAMA
GOING ON THERE.
>> YEAH.
>> NEXT UP, YOU KNOW KATY
PERRY'S "ROAR," RIGHT? ALREADY
FUN TO LISTEN TO. WELL, WHAT
IF WE FLIP THAT AND MADE IT
THE WORD "CHORE."
HOW WOULD THAT MANIFEST?
>> ♪ MORNING, MORNING
AND NIGHT ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I AM A FARMER
♪ AND THEY WANT TO SEE ME
CHORE ♪
>> GUYS WHAT IS THE NAME OF
THIS MUSICAL ACT?
>> HARI.
>> ADAM AND STEVE AND STEVE.
>> YES, POINTS.
POINTS.
(LAUGHTER)
MATT BRAUNGER, LET'S GO WITH
YOU.
>> BAND IS CALLED SLAYER...OF
COWS!
>> YES, POINTS.
>> OR WHEN THEY DO ACOUSTIC
IT'S GRIM BEEFER.
>> OH, SO GOOD.
GRIM BEEFER IS GREAT.
>> DUDE.
>> Chris: I FEEL LIKE AFTER
"GRIM BEEFER," YOU HAVE TO
RETIRE FROM COMEDY. THAT'S IT.
>> SOMEONE WANTS ME TO
TONIGHT.
>> DON'T LISTEN THEM, ALL
RIGHT.
>> I DON'T MEAN THEM, I MEAN
A GUY AT HOME. I WILL [BLEEP]
YOU.
>> Chris: HOW ABOUT THIS CLASSIC
SITCOM THEME FROM "FRESH PRINCE
OF BEL-AIR" REMIXED
FARMER-STYLE, THE WAY IT WAS
MEANT TO BE.
>> WHEN WE FINISH WITH THAT
WE DO OUR BEST TO PROVIDE
BY GROWING ALL YOUR FOOD UP IN
THE COUNTRYSIDE.
WE MAKE SURE TO BE SAFE SO
OUR MOM'S
NOT SCARED. SHE SAYS,
>> FARMING CAN BE DANGEROUS
SO BE PREPARED.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: NOW IF THIS WERE
AN INTRO TO AN ACTUAL
SITCOM WHAT WOULD IT BE
CALLED?
>> "HOW I MET YOUR MOTHER, MY
SISTER."